ce matin dès l'aube les agriculteurs ont
manifesté pour faire entendre leur
ras-le-bol
ils ont répondu à la mobilisation lancé
par la fédération nationale des
syndicats d'exploitants agricoles et des
jeunes agriculteurs
parmi les manifestants cet agriculteur
installé depuis quatre ans sur 170
hectares
là c'est vraiment un cumul de tous
aujourd'hui on nous parle de 350 mètres
aux abords des maisons de zones de
traitement donc pour lui ça c'est un
scandale totalement parce que c'est une
perte de revenu sur ces bandes là qui va
payer les fermages aux propriétaires qui
va indemniser l'agriculteur sur les
pertes
les agriculteurs ont mené l'opération
escargot départ de base en ville ils se
sont dirigés sur la nationale 12 pour
rejoindre un autre cortège à montfort
l'amaury ils ont regagné le triangle de
rocquencourt pour se fondre avec les
tracteurs qui arrivait de mantes la
jolie dans le cortège beaucoup de
pancartes macron à répond elle les
agriculteurs se sont délaissés par le
gouvernement le gouvernement veut
peut-être aujourd'hui que l'on devienne
des fonctionnaires de l'état d'entretien
de la nature c'est à dire peut-être que
dans dix ans on va recevoir 1500 euros
par mois pour va entretenir les champs
pour faire plaisir au gouvernement parce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est ce qu'on a la
pression on est lâché
c'est tout bonnement un ras-le-bol
j'arrive en fin de carrière mais je
voudrais bien aimé finir plus calmement
et puis je suis inquiet pour les jeunes
qui viennent derrière parce que bon ben
ça va quand même être très difficile la
loi dite et galim issues des états
généraux de l'alimentation est mis en
place en début d'année était censé
ramener du revenu aux exploitants en
rééquilibrant les relations commerciales
pourtant ce céréalier et éleveur ne
perçoit pas de différence et l'expriment
sur ces panneaux français vêtue encore
de thé agriculteurs l'agriculture
française c'est une des premières
puissances économiques du pays et on tue
cette agriculture on tue cette économie
on alerte
demain aujourd'hui on est capable de
nourrir notre population demain on va
importer et on mangera du grand
n'importe quoi et ça c'est vraiment jeu
ça me désole pour mes enfants pour mes
petits neveux pour mes voisins et pour
tous les français
les agriculteurs se sont ensuite dirigés
sur le périphérique parisien pour tous
se rejoindre sur l'avenue foch à 10h30
le 23 septembre dernier et les
agriculteurs s'étaient déjà mobilisés
dans plusieurs départements d'île de
france